education has moved in about the same
way everything public has moved frankly
ana.k to 6 degree and everything you do
is micromanage by a district a state
legislature a Department of Education
today schools have a deficit of cultural
literacy they have a deficit of
knowledge about the human world in the
natural world I think there's a
prevailing sense that students are
graduating just adrift in general or
unclear on what life is for the founders
knew that an educated citizenry was
necessary to the health of the Republic
so the impacts of this can be seen from
individual lives all the way out to our
nation today once I really started doing
my research on class go ahead I kind of
realized that this was the missing piece
and this is what raises good strong
college students and eventually good
strong adults make it happen Monica I
want a beautiful left hands active
school
Barney charter school initiative is an
outreach of Hillsdale College and it's
an excellent way to reintroduce sound
learning the classical liberal arts
based education that was a hundred years
ago common
here at Hillsdale we don't take any
money from the government so we don't
take any money from these schools but we
offer them help we serve as the
architect of the academic program or an
advisor to these schools so that they
can't offer this kind of excellent
education
[Music]
we're much more focused on the
individual student and making them a
well-rounded human being it's their
ability to understand the world around
them to be able to hold a conversation
with an adult it's a sign of hope for me
because there is a desire and a
recognition that education is vital that
we need to do something to restore it
and thousands of children attending
excellent schools having their character
shaped has exciting prospects for this
country
[Music]